e
good morning everybody Welcome to
Transportation uh before we get started
with our hearings if we could all rise
okay thank you I'm just going to make
one announcement uh there was some
confusion there was an error made in the
public hearing list I'll take the
responsibility
um the calendar was listed as saying
host Bill 209 with a continued public
hearing that is an error uh I did close
the public hearing last week there is no
reason for me to reopen it again it was
just a typo we didn't discover the uh
error until beyond the 24hour notice
window so I couldn't make the correction
and just letting you know now that
hearing has been closed so we will get
into our first hearing at 10:20 on House
minutes
e
on House Bill
305 relative to speed and red light
cameras for traffic enforcement uh chair
recognizes the prime sponsor
sir thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
I feel like it's old home
week it's great to be
here uh as you know I'm I'm not a person
of many words I just keep it short so
and that's what I intend to do today
um today I'm presenting uh House Bill
305 relatives to speed and red light
cameras for traffic
enforcement um every one of you lives
someplace in New Hampshire and every
community in New Hampshire is having
trouble finding police officers I know
the the state police at one time were
down 40 people I don't know what the the
current is right now uh in Kean where I
am and I'm also a city counselor in Kean
we were down 11 people at one time I
think we've got it down to minus four
right now so having police officers out
there monitoring traffic is tough right
now the other issue that's bothering us
across the state is more and more
erratic driving especially by younger
people uh we see it everywhere um just
yesterday in Kean we had a a gentleman
get run over by a vehicle and then two
other
vehicles uh just because of erratic
driving it's it's it's happening
everywhere and this is just a tool to
help those that need it um I'm just
going to summarize the bill I'm not
going to read it the bill introduces a
new section to the existing law allowing
a mines pality I to install and utilize
traffic enforcement cameras included
speed monitoring monitoring and red
light cameras at their discretion the
municipalities will be responsible for
the costs associated with the
installation and maintenance of these
camera systems and that's important I'll
talk about that in a minute additionally
they must collaborate with the
Department of Transportation and
Department of Safety to ensure that
cameras are installed and operated in
compliance with state and federal laws
the bill EMP emphasizes that the
municipalities will be held liable for
any lawful operations of the unlawful
operations of the camera system uh the
difference between us and the other
states that
have traffic cameras many of them use a
third party uh where they're working on
a
commission they they get the data on the
driver they send the tickets and they
get a commission from the municipality
I purposely avoided that we don't
want we don't want that in New Hampshire
uh the city the municipalities have full
control there is no third party there is
no spreading of information among
private companies and there's
no last minute uh trying to trying to
get
through I think it's very simple it's
just uh something to help uh all of our
Municipal police departments
and I would gladly take any questions Mr
chair thank you sir questions from the
committee represent Miller thank you Mr
chair thank you for your testimony I'm
curious you mentioned that they would
have to be administered by the
municipalities rather than a third party
yes um are there products out there that
are available that do that I feel like
this is one of those things when the
third parties get involved and manage
all those systems sometimes they sort of
take over the ecosystem and there
wouldn't even be a product
available thank you for that very good
question they are and you are correct
there are products out there um many
states use that third party product uh
and that's what we don't want here um I
work as a um a manufacturers rep I
travel all over and uh I see it in many
cities where they have that uh Province
Rhode Island for some reason my ways
system tells me when there's a camera
ahead it must give off some kind of
system or something like that the third
party cameras uh just don't seem to be
working and there's more complaints
about the third party cameras that's why
I specifically put this in the hands of
the
municipalities thank you
sir representative
Gorski thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question and welcome
back um can you go over again what the
list of violations that these cameras
would be looking
for it's it's mostly speeding erratic
follow so let's say someone runs Rod
light and this camera catches it what's
the process if someone get like a like a
bill in the mail or violation in the
mail to say here's a ticket how how does
that all work uh well each municipality
would handle it their own way that's
that's the other beauty of this that the
municipalities can determine how it will
be done um I
know good lawyer would CH if somebody
does get uh a violation of summons a
good lawyer would challenge it in court
but good lawyers also challenge radar
speed radar guns and they also
challenged the height I seen them try
challenge the height of a stop sign
because it was 4 in too low they
uh they went
free thank
you any other questions from the
committee represent gon thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
sir in a multi-driver household uh who
is going to be acre the fine and the
points on their license or any driving
record for um a pattern of
misconduct thank you for your question
that's a very good question um and the
answer is it it's up to the enforcement
agency to enforce that um if they don't
have a a good line of sight on the on
the actual driver it probably works
against them they'll probably have to
filter that system so that they can do
it um uh you you did bring out one of
the problems that they have with the uh
with the other camera systems with the
third party they just give it based on
the on the license plate we don't want
that in New Hampshire we want it we want
driver thank you representative
hlin thank you Mr chair um thank you for
being here so to follow up on
representative gon's question um what if
I'm driving a rental car or a company
car that's registered to an entity as
opposed to a
person thank you for that question
that's a very good one
um I'll be it'll be hard to enforce that
that would be something that would be
very hard to enforce this isn't the
catch all for everything it's just going
to be some help for police especially
when you got local people who are
consistent violators those are the
people they want to go after not the
visitor coming in a rental car um but
you're right that could that could be a
experience yeah follow up thank you um a
different is there a question of due
process on this if I go to court to
contest my ticket I can confront a
policeman who had pulled me over but I
camera another good question thank you
sir uh
well it would still have to come from an
officer this is only a tool the same
thing as if he's using a radar gun he
still had it's still an officer issuing
the
summons I'll give you one more in that
one yep thank you U so a traffic camera
generally is mounted on a pole on the
street there is no officer involved
okay um actually I I have one just just
for clarity um you're saying that these
cameras not only can but should capture
not just the license plate but the
operator
also depends on which camera system they
use but uh if they have a good one yes
okay thank you anybody else from the
committee representative St
Clair thank you Mr chair and uh good
morning I'm out at night I'm sitting at
a light for whatever reason it's
malfunctioning it will not change they
give me the green light I treat it as a
stop sign at that point and go through
it
safely now I'm going to get a ticket
from a machine that says I ran a red
light I've got no officer who stopped me
that I can explain it to on the spot and
they can either then they can make a
judgment right there I'm not going to
have to go to court at some cost either
through missed work uh get a lawyer
whatever uh what about what about that
situation thank you for the question
representative and uh first of all you
would probably be excused because you'd
have your motorcycle helmet on so they
you uh but it's it's not the machine
that's doing the that's record that's uh
enforcing the violation it the machine
is just being used as a tool to help
enforce especially with uh when we have
people that are are uh continued
violators it's not the catch all for
everything I don't know it could be a
catchall for a lot of things uh anybody
else from the committee seeing none
thank you very much thank you sir uh
next up shair recognizes Edward H uh
from Kean representing himself and
sir uh thank you Mr chairman yes uh my M
hos I'm representing myself I'm also a
city counselor and Keen working with uh
representative Jones as well um but we
23613 which governs uh Highway video
surveillance at this time um these uh
type of detection systems are used in at
least 19 States depending on where you
research you get different numbers um
but at least 19 states are using them
and and there's more coming every day as
I follow the news either uh local cities
or or other states coming on board um
they're typically used in places where
you're really concerned about the speed
or the red lights now you're not putting
them on every red light that would not
be cost effective whatsoever but you're
putting on them in places where you've
done a study to understand that they are
of value and they're typically also used
in school zones in hospital zones um in
uh and in particular they're used in
construction zones and construction
zones we all know is one of the most
hazardous uh job hazardous occupations
in America today a highway construction
worker is so much more likely to be
injured or killed uh and other
additional U controls of that would
always be welcome now there's right now
in um New Hampshire we have they're
prohibited from local jurisdictions to
deploy them and that's what we'd like to
amend but we allow them in so many
places already there's at least 10
exceptions here uh that uh allow uh
speed control cameras uh to regulate the
traffic uh uh movement the um also uh
the department of Department of
Transportation is allowed to operate
dash cameras in their Fleet now they're
not doing law enforcement work but
they're recording the data and uh
monitoring traffic as as these type uh
detection systems would do um there's
some typical uh regulations that go
along with
this and they're here
somewhere there they are uh so you know
first you do a needs analysis you know
if a local jurisdiction is authorized to
do this they have to do a needs analysis
which would then work with state do uh
to justify it um an annual report of all
the detections records infractions
summonses and any fines that might be
generated could uh would be required and
and could be produced and made public
record um violations as a result of
detection would not exceed anything that
would be uh issued by usual police
detection uh violations in some states
don't result in points on an owner's
license it's recognized that this is
something something new and we're
exploring it and we you move into it
carefully but you don't make it any
worse than what might be there already
and as uh representative Jones mentioned
the vendors are only paid for the value
of the equipment there's never never a
performance uh uh reward for how many
detections they get um the uh you these
things are we're all familiar with
silent policemen or or even a cruiser
parked on the side of the road uh at the
effect the impact that that has this is
one more enhancement uh to those to that
abilities you know we all slow down when
we see those things
coming last things um I mentioned
construction zones so these really act
as a safety device uh and will help uh
reduce people's speed in in dangerous uh
areas and there also a law enforcement
safety device if we have some way to
lessen the number of of Troopers of
policemen have to stand on the side of a
a fast moving Road a busy highway uh and
uh stopping Speeders if we have other
ways to do that we're improving their
job safety and their job
performance thank
you thank you sir I just got one
question uh the bill says on line F five
actually four and five that systems May
shall be used for traffic enforcement
only uh I've heard from you and the
previous speaker that there there only
for certain things in traffic
enforcement and you've mentioned
yourself of several guard rails like uh
the needs assessment and and um studies
determining where and when uh Etc I
guess my question is where are all those
guard rails written down in the bill I I
I look to the committee to help develop
that I recognize this is a new step for
New Hampshire legislation and uh we we
need to explore how it could be done and
I I'm sure it would be great to have
whatever guard rails you want as long as
we can create the path for local
jurisdictions to to do
this any other questions from the
committee thank you by the way represent
pyo thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
H for uh taking my question here you
mentioned in your testimony that there
are um exceptions or examples that we
have um detection cameras and Ed by the
state level um is there anything if you
could clarify that a little sure um
they're they're used on Bridges around
Portsmouth and Nashua
and it's it's listed in the existing
bill which I thought I had right there
it is um used on exit ramps and entrance
uh exit ramps off i93 and i8 9 they're
used uh they're authorized in any future
state-owned Park and Ride
facility uh and I mentioned the dot dash
cams um and and when you think about it
they're used by police dash cams already
uh it's the same type of uh situation
where we're using an electronic
detection device to record somebody's
vehicle may I ask a followup sir y
follow
um let's say there's a high traffic
intersection in a
municipality um is there something
stopping from the municipality appealing
to the state to put in detection cameras
there in their circumstance well uh
thank you um as as I read the existing
legislation I'm no lawyer here so uh
forgive me um the local jurisdictions
are strictly prohibited from deploying
any such detection
devices thank you other
questions represent
a thank you Mr chairman um could this
system be used in real time for example
you have multiple cameras at multiple
stop lights somebody runs a stoplight
the data is caught by the system but
there's a
live uh person at say police
headquarters who can then give that
information to the police officer and
they can go pick him up in in real time
as opposed to later on by mail thanks
what a great question um first thing
comes to mind is I say yeah if you're
driving a Tesla I'm sure it could be
wired directly to shut your car off at
that time but I understand what you're
saying could it be reviewed that sure um
but that's a very labor intensive
operation I think we' uh we're putting
so much of the burden to uh justify
operate and then uh utilize the results
of these detections on the local
jurisdiction they have to want it really
bad and many actually do so um could
that happen sure if we want to pay for a
law enforcement officer sitting there
watching this at all times more as far
as I understand other states that do it
um will you know review the detections
it it pops up on a beeper or something
and then it has to be reviewed because
if they're going to issue a summons uh
as representative Jones said it has to
be done by a law enforcement
official thank
you anybody else we do have somebody
from do here if it helps I don't know
what that question is representative St
Clair thank you Mr chair and thank you
um I I like what you said about uh you
put up signs now to warn people about
speed zones Etc is there anything to
prevent uh well say Keen from putting up
a sign that says uh traffic or speed
cameras in effect even though there's
not one there but just kind of put it up
there is like a this will get in the
slow down a little bit because I bring
this up because the city of Daytona
Beach in Florida had speed cameras
everywhere and they um they took them
down but they left all the signs up
which uh I think probably keeps people
maybe a little more honest so it's just
question yeah there always um I think uh
you go into retail stores and you see
security cameras and you wonder what are
they actually looking at um the um you
know that that is something that always
seems good uh until people figure it out
and it's doesn't take long I mean the
recent example was over in Chesterfield
on route nine where uh City uh parked an
empty police cruiser on the side of the
road and people were just jamming on
their brakes when they came up to see
that for a couple days and then he
realized there's nobody in the damn
moves oh represent
Sinclair but the outer Towners won't
know that thank you was there a question
there the Out of Towners won't know that
will
they uh I have one last one just getting
back to the actual language of the bill
um it says that municipality shall be
jointly and serly liable for any
unlockable operation of any camera
system again
and I should have asked the prime
sponsor but you've been working with him
so I'll ask you
um what does that look like or is that
also a charge of the committee to figure
out what that looks like no I I think
that's an open-ended statement that will
allow U the that we really lays it on
the individual municipality the
jurisdiction to be responsible for the
operation and they'll be subject to all
the usual 91a uh requirements and um
obviously we know there'll be core
challenges it's a it's a heavy lift for
a municipality to engage this but um if
they really want to the state should
allow them to do
so anybody else seeing none we do have
one more speaker from the Department of
Transportation thank you very much thank
you chair recognizes Bill Lambert from
the New Hampshire Department of
Transportation not taking a position on
the
bill good morning oh thank you Mr chair
members of the committee for the record
my name is Bill Lambert I'm the highway
safety AC of Transportation
administrator for the Department of
Transportation and prior to that I spent
several years as a state traffic
engineer so the department is neutral on
the bill um I operate I put in the pink
card in case there's any technical
questions that I that I can try to help
out with um the one example I can get
that's kind of similar to what I see in
the bill is uh the speed uh feedback
signs that a lot of you are probably
familiar with your speed is um we allow
those U by local Juris PRS on state
highways um but we get a lot of
variation how they deployed um vendors
will sell a lot of Technology they'll
promise a lot of things um but
delivering the technology isn't always
as efficient as we and consistent as we
would like so with that I'd be happy to
take any questions I'd also be happy if
there's no
questions not so
lucky seriously though um the cameras
that we currently allow whether it's the
ones that control red lights on the
telephone poles or at the tolls
collecting uh plate
information do we have any that collect
other than images of traffic or license
plates currently I mean because this one
and the reason I asked do we have any
that are intended to capture the
occupant couple different types of
cameras so uh the previous speaker
mentioned um some of the security
cameras in this bridge security cameras
uh on the high level Bridge those kind
of went in with 91 911 the homeland
security issues um kind of a high
Transportation asset so those cameras
capture video um they're not uh high
resolution video but they capture video
uh and it's not of the highway
necessarily it's the structure itself
the um the toll evasion cameras are
strictly plate I think that's very
strictly regulated in the in the law
that we're only allowed to capture plate
and we only um site the owner of the
vehicle U so we don't identify who the
driver is um and then the traffic signal
detection that's simply technology to
allow us to to identify that as a
vehicle waiting we don't record any of
that video there's nothing captured
there that's just historically we've
used the inductive Loops in the pavement
um they're very hard to replace in the
winter time uh so we end up with traffic
signals with no detection for several
months until we can fix it um and while
that's reliable most of the time uh the
the detection cameras allow us um to be
able to respond to a failed detection
rather immediately but there's no
recording of that that's the cameras
that I'm the 93 and 89 exit ramp cameras
I'm I'm not familiar with what those
might be so I can't answer
that okay those are the parking ride
ones you're not sure on those park and
ride goes into the same security issue
as as the um the bridge cameras they're
there for security that's police video
um we can monitor it live to make sure
that there's nothing going on that we
need to send resources
for thank you sir any other questions
from the
committee seeing none thank you very
right um I have nobody else signed to
signed up to speak on House Bill 35 so
I'm going to close the public hearing uh
a few minutes to reset we will move into
you
e
okay I'm going to open up the public
hearing on House Bill
368 prohibiting smoking and ecigarettes
and motor vehicles on a passenger under
16 years of age is the prime sponsor
I do not see her I do have the right
bill right
1040 um as a courtesy when people can't
make it I did not hear from the prime
sponsor so you know but we uh are here
to have the public hearing so if I can
get somebody from the committee to
introduce it as a courtesy that would be
good morning Mr chairman uh Seth Miller
uh representative uh from Dover um
introducing House Bill
368 uh this is a bill that requires uh
no person shall smoke tobacco products
or ecigarettes in a motor vehicle at any
time when a child of under the age of 16
is in the vehicle uh it calls for a $100
fine as a penalty and it is listed as a
secondary action only I have no ability
to answer questions but if you want to
ask them anyways I'm happy to try no we
won't subject you to that thank you
thank you um and speaking of that I have
nobody signed up to speak for it or
against it uh I will just let the
committee know I believe this is the
third time we've seen this probably at
least the third time so with no other uh
with nobody else signed up to speak I'm
going to close the public hearing on
House Bill
368 we get caught right back up next
hearing is at 11 House Bill 390 we'll
then
e
to adding retired fire apparatus fire
trucks to antique vehicle exemptions and
the chair like
to bring up
Representative Steve Parson who is the
Transportation thank you Mr chair thank
you transportation for once again
indulging me
legislation so House Bill 390 let me uh
let me paint the picture for you here in
and this all starts off with uh nothing
to do with firet trucks in 2007 we had a
gentleman in the state of New Hampshire
create a car that looked an awful lot
like a cop car and he decided it would
be fun to pull women over and have
conversations with
them so looking through the statute at
the time they could not charge him with
that there was no prohibition
specifically to that with a with a
vehicle so the legislature in 2008
reacted and reacted quickly and when we
react quickly with legislation based on
events sometimes we make
mistakes so the legislature did is they
put a section into law that prohibited
and they used the term emergency
vehicles
now following that event and following
that
legislation the Department of Motor
Vehicles went with the interpretation of
intent on that and they did it for 16
years with no
issue now fast forward to around 9
months ago I get a call from a gentleman
in Salem who owns an antique fire engine
went down to the clerk to re-register as
he had done for the prior 20 years and
was told by the clerk now can't register
that anymore you can't have that on the
road so he said how do you figure out
I've been doing this I've had this thing
for over 20 years and she said new law
well now now there was no new
law so I get this call from from him and
others in that universe that owned
antique fire engines and said what the
heck is going on here so I called the
director of the DMV and asked that very
question well with the and I commend the
director of the Department of Motor
Vehicles in this in this Venture here in
the sense that he's he was relatively
new at the time and was literally going
through the statute looking section by
section to make sure his agency complied
with the law which which is great I wish
every state agency did
that but when it got to this point under
strict
interpretation he said well because of
the way it's written that's kind of how
it
is so we had a discussion about intent
and some of the absurdity of that and
what that actually translates
to and he said well there's also a
conflict in statute and there's another
section of Statute that allows for the
use of lights and sirens in parades I
said that's great but how you get the
parade so um so in discussions with the
um the chairman of both health and
Senate transportation in discussions
with uh some folks in that Universe I
said you know what we just we need to
fix this
so okay why does that matter and I'll
give you a great example of the
technicalities of the law if you're
going to be under strict interpretation
the town of Raymond a fire department I
actually worked for um has a 19 30 Maxum
it was purchased new by the town
literally in 1930 they've had it ever
since but in the 1980s the technical
ownership of that firetruck was
transferred to the Raymond historic
Association so under strict
interpretation of the law because the
vehicle is not owned by a municipal fire
department they can't put it in parades
anymore 50 years that vehicle has
transported either Miss Raymond or Miss
New Hampshire in the town
parade but technically cannot do it now
to do it they would have to strip
everything off of it now I had a a
lovely lady at the Department of Motor
Vehicles say to me well you know you you
you have to take all the stuff off that
makes it a firet Tru and I said Well
ma'am I you know if we if you painted a
firetruck purple and you drove it down
the road people would go oh look at that
that's a purple firet truck it's a
utilitarian vehicle made for a purpose
unlike a cop car which is a Dodge
Charger with stickers decals and license
plates that if you remove stickers decal
license plates it just goes back to
being a Dodge Charger well fire trucks
don't really do that so in working with
the Department of Motor Vehicles we kind
of came up with an idea of how we can
make this fit in here and make this work
so the legislation what that does is it
it puts retired fire apparatus under the
antique standard why first of all
they're antiques secondly because
antique vehicles cannot be used for
Commerce and that's kind of important
here because it is possible for someone
actually it has occurred As a treat
company in plastow that owns a retired
ladder truck and they use it for tree
trimming purposes this bill does not
exempt them because they use it for
commercial purposes and therefore cannot
register it as an antique so what this
does is it puts the the retired fire
apparatus into the antique statute and
then what it does is under the
prohibition part it exempts them from
the requirements of having to strip the
vehicle down into nothing
now literally someone at the DMV told
this guy that he had to take a razor
blade to the side of his vehicle and
remove everything off of it no one is
going to take an antique and do that
that that's the the absurdity of that is
I can't believe it came out of
somebody's mouth frankly but um having
been in this universe for a long time I
can tell you I can assure you we don't
have problems in New Hampshire with
people doing things with anti fire
engines they're not supposed to be it is
against the law for them to run on a
public road with sirens on it always has
been and it will continue to be and none
of them do it none of them risk that
this is a a very tight community ofo of
just historic people fire service
history people people that want to
preserve old fire
apparatus these these people are are
very proud of of what they do and
they're very cognizant of the damage
they can do to their Community we do not
have a problem in New Hampshire with
this so this is just a matter of
taking a strict interpretation of the
law tweaking it a little
bit and solving a problem before it
really becomes any
bigger and I'm absolutely open to
questions thank you so much any
questions from the
committee
representative thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my question so we already
know in New Hampshire statute that
impersonating a law enforcement officer
you know is it covers using lights and
siren to pull somebody over uh and is a
felony and using emergency vehicle
lights and sirens is uh I believe a
major misdemeanor to do the same to move
somebody out of traffic this does not
affect those laws it simply says that
you don't have to modify something for
the use of parades Etc so this
absolutely does not have anything to do
with police vehicles in any way shape or
form this is strictly just anti
fire engines
right so
looking fire engines are not hard to
hide right they look like fire engines
it's this isn't a matter of going
well you know is what are we looking at
here it's a fire Tru right so this is
not this is not going to enable anybody
to do anything illegal it does not
change that portion of Statute in any
way shape or form and if someone has
ever successfully pull someone over in a
firet truck I'd like to meet him cuz
that would be a pretty impressive
event any other questions with committee
representative pataro um in developing
this bill uh you did find that using the
word apparatus is correct um re reason I
asked with fire departments and fire
apparatus I it could be anything it
could be
um um chemical canisters or or what have
you I can't even imagine but I just
wanted to make sure I'm clear on that so
apparatus is an industry
term it's it's how um within the fire
service things are defined
and where where apparatus is important
in not using the term vehicle right
there are vehicles that are owned by the
fire fire departments that are not fire
apparatus they don't fight fire right so
the fire the city Fire Marshall in
Manchester driving around in his Chevy
that's not a fire apparatus so fire
apparatus is is important an important
distinction there in the sense that it
defines a vehicle in a certain
way follow up Sir follow up um you say
apparatus is an industry term are we
aware of any like description any other
part of the legislation for these sorts
of things no it doesn't I don't think
that we need to get into the the other
parts of law where fire apparatus is
discussed it it's this is there's no
loophole here there's no it again
there the idea here is to is to
allow antique fire engines to continue
to do what they've been doing in the
state for a hundred years that that's
why that term has to be used it's not
for pickup trucks it's not for ancillary
staff cars those are not considered fire
apparatus by any municipality or fire
department so it's I I hate to use the
term common terminology but but that's
just that's really what that term means
it's it's a common terminology thank
thank you for the clarification
representative Miller uh thank you chair
and thank you for taking the question is
there a reason that we've specified a
different age for the fire apparatus
versus other antique Vehicles yes there
is is it just because this happened to
be the age of this one or is there
unlike cop cars that you will not see a
20-year-old cop car on the road in New
Hampshire they have rotten to dust okay
um the reason for 20 years is because
the service life of a fire engine in New
Hampshire now due to the crap that we
spray on the roads has dwindled down to
years it used to be a lot longer than
that so 20 years was done for the sake
of how do we take a a fire engine that
has gone to municipal auction and
purchased by someone with the intent of
preserving it and now they sit in this
window where okay I've acquired this 20y
old 21y old fir Tru that's now no longer
being used and I have to park it out
back for five years waiting for the
antique standard to catch up to the
reality of what it is that's that's the
reason 20 years was chosen um and again
that was also in consultation with the
DM director
so any other questions from the
committee representative plemon thank
you thank you for Mr chair and thank you
for taking the question I just looking
for some clarification you you stated
that this is the fire apparatus not the
pickups um so what about like command
type Vehicles Hazmat Vehicles a lot of
fire departments have their own
ambulances all respond to fires and such
um would they they would not be in
included and then why not should they be
included so ambulances are not
specifically included in this because
and perhaps that your chairman will
will explain this to you in in exec
session but ambulances retired
ambulances are typically used by
contractors plumbers folks like that not
the intent here um you know you want to
into I mean the oh my gosh probably I'd
have to think of the newest preserved
ambulance I've ever seen for restoration
purposes is out of the 50s it it's just
not something that's that's done they
ambulance has ambulances haven't changed
the way they look since the 70s they're
just not something that's restored or or
kept so ambulances were specifically not
mentioned in this because of the fact
again like I said the majority of them
that end up in private hands that have
survived past being rotten like are used
followup follow up what about the other
items I identified like Hazmat vehicles
uh C4 trucks command
Vehicles yep those are um they're not a
Hazmat rig would be would fall under the
apparatus definition command Vehicles
would have to fall under the generic
antique standard they're not they're not
fire apparatus so they're not the intent
of this legislation is not to protect
those vehicles at all
any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you sir
thank you Mr chair chair and I like to
recognize uh representative PRL who is
bill good morning Mr chairman and the
members of the committee uh pretty much
ditto but I I heard uh something about
risking their apparatus doing something
illegal because when you pay lots of
money for it invest lots of money into
it to fix it back up to where it is you
do not want to risk it by doing
something stupid like driving down the
road with your lights and sirens on and
I can also attest that I've never heard
anybody doing that with one of their
antique fire trucks except in the parade
where it's supposed to happen so I would
really appreciate uh you passing this
and ambulances were dealt with a few
years back still don't agree with that
and you may see me in here for those
because those need to be preserved as
well it's very true contractors use them
but there are also people who actually
like EMS who preserve those as well
because they're a part of our history uh
as well and with that if you have any
questions for me I'll take them but any
question very good any questions from
the committee going once going twice not
seeing any thank you so much thank you
guys I do not have anybody else who's
registered to speak so I'm going to
close the public hearing on HB
390 our next bill uh will be HB 419
about five
minutes
e
windshield wipers are also on chair
recognizes representative Jones Prime
sponsor welcome
back thank you Mr
chair once again representative Philip
3 I'm here today representing all of
your constituents all of your mothers
and fathers and daughters and sons and
brothers and sisters anyone who drives
in New
Hampshire uh I'm
here asking for four simple words added
to an
and I think in the fourth line down it
says and whenever windshield wipers are
are active that's the only four words
we're adding to that
RSA uh it's a difference between seeing
somebody who's 100 feet away or somebody
that's 900 feet away uh so it's for the
best of all of us uh as I said earlier
I'm not one per many words uh I did send
you all a an email about uh from the US
Department of
Transportation about survey that was
done uh first of all we would be joining
18 other states in having such a such a
law uh the US do sent us information on
a survey done by The renir
Institute and what they did was they
took seven states that had those laws
they did a comparison of the same time
period before those States had the laws
and after and the difference
in those laws came out that there excuse
it it
was
7% less accidents less fatal accidents
on inclement weather days after the law
was passed and 30% less at Dusk and Dawn
so that's the only scientific data I
could find but I think it's very
important to have
that and so it's very simple put your
put your lights on when your wipers when
your wipers are on that's all we ask and
chair I just have one and I'm not trying
to be nitpicky about it but in terms of
enforceability know because I I see a
lot of these that could be done through
public education especially the the the
Billboards on the side of the road that
are programmable what is law enforcement
and how are they supposed to enforce
somebody that either has their
windshield wipers on low intermittent or
off because the way this is written if
they're off they don't need their
headlights but if it's on low
intermittent they would how do they tell
the
difference that's that's a very good
question I get low intermittent you're
still going to see the wiper go by
while again how do they know that's my
that was my question but thank you any
other otherwise they wouldn't enforce it
I guess you know any other questions
represent gon thank you Mr chair thank
you so this adding to an existing law on
on uh headlight usage you know dust Dawn
Etc is the intent in terms of
enforcement that it would be the same
fine as inappropriate use of headlights
is it because it's kind of added on to
that so is that how it's enforcable yes
questions represent St
Clair thank you and thank you uh do you
have any idea of of the percentage of
how many vehicles are on the highway
where their lights are on all the time
manufacturer I don't have that kind of
data but that just helps we wouldn't
have to
enforce thank
you represent
pataro thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question uh in your estimation
if this bill were to pass and be law
would I be faced with a situation if I'm
driving up North and a dragon fly hits
my windshield and I use the wipers to
get it off and I could be breaking the
headlights well I think any enforcement
officer would have to use discretion
when it comes to
that you're right it could be just like
any any other law has could be with it
to that's correct I they'd have to use
discretion thank you
representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question welcome back to Transportation
thank you sir um I have two vehicles
that have a um a feature that um it
senses when there's moisture on the
window and it and it operates the
windshield wipers automatically um I
have no idea how I
would uh ever stop to make this work
with that kind of bill um do you have
any ideas how that would uh interfere or
work with your process on this
legislation well that's a very good
question thank you for the question um
yes it it could happen uh and my wife
does have a car that turns on the uh the
F minute Fields Mo uh moisture the uh
the what the wipers will go on once
again it's it's a discretion of the
enforcement officer plus I'm pretty sure
if you have that option you already have
your running lights on when you're when
you're driving because that that would
option represent
Johnson thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question would daytime
running lights
Bill thank you representative that's a
very good question they I think the
headlights we could we could amend it to
saying uh running lights but I think uh
the bill specifically States headlights
because that's what in Clement weather
that's the one that makes the difference
between being 100 feet away or 900 feet
away thank
you representative pondon thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my
question does do it the statement in the
legislation whenever rain snow and fog
shall interfere with the proper view of
the road does that not
clarify the terms when the windshield
wipers in conjunction with the headlight
should be on is that specifi it's kind
of specific to inclimate
weather thank you so that answers your
question I think I believe right sir
thank you thank you Mr
chair anybody else
representative pay you thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question um so all these conditions
would have to be met in order for you to
be in violation of the law you're it
would have to be snow rain fog uh view
of the road person's Vehicles c not
clearly discernable at 1 th000 ft and
whenever windshield wipers are active so
that's what the bill all those
conditions would have to be
met in
that's a good question that's the way
so and that answer some of the other
set okay that answers the dead bug
question anybody else from the committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
sir uh next up chair Rec
recognizes Edward hos from Kean
representing himself in support of the
bill looking for a mere two minutes
sir is it on now yeah
um higher visibility is so important in
any sorry if I can get you to introduce
yourself again just for the record
Edward hos Keen I'm also a city
councelor in Kean um in support of a
bill um higher visibility for
automobiles is so critical for road
safety um we motorcycles have that
already that they have their lights on
Modern cars have some combination of
headlight or running light not the
classic parking light that some of us uh
1970 car people are familiar with it's
not the parking lights with that first
Notch there is a setting that actually
illuminates the headlights early on um
the higher visibility is good not only
for the driver but for other vehicles
seeing that automobile I speak uh
experience as a cyclist and I have a
rearview mirror I can immediately see a
car from behind when he has the lights
on um I cannot see a car from behind
when he has no lights on he just Fades
into the woods so I I would uh in
support of higher visibility of
automobiles in any case and certainly
when um there's these conditions as
stated in the Bill thank you one
minute on where am I House Bill
419 so with that I'll close the public
hearing um I had built this time in for
just in case and we have no just in case
so looks like we have a a long lunch or
a lunch in some caucus time so uh we'll
be back for our executive session at
1:00 uh no sorry public hearing on 4:14
at
1:00
e
I'll open up the public hearing on host
Bill 414 FN prohibiting the division of
motor vehicles from suspending a license
on the basis of debt owed to a private
entity related to the towing or storing
of a motor
vehicle and much I don't have any pink
and so the chair recognizes the prime
sponsor representative Reed welcome to
Transportation thank you again Mr chair
and thank you again honorable members
for having me back uh again for the
record my name is Ellen Reed I represent
Rockingham 10 which is New Market and
new
Fields so I don't know how aware of the
current law you are in this particular
regard but it is currently the legal
condition and in fact the practice of
the
state for when for example let's say and
I'm going to use a low to moderate
income person as an example because it
exacerbates the issue drastically let's
say a person is driving um and gets
T-boned or rear ended something that's
not even their fault their car which may
not have been a high dollar car to begin
with is completely total the police
arrive on the scene the police call
their choice of towing company the
person has no choice in what towing
company the police are going to use the
police have the towing company remove
the
vehicle um and then store the vehicle
until the person can get it out current
law says they have 14 days to claim it
and they can get their personal
belongings in the
meantime if that vehicle is totaled and
if there was no insurance since we don't
require Insurance in the state to pay
for the cost of that Collision again it
may not have even been that person's
fault that person now has to pay the
several hundred to the towing company
for removing the vehicle even though
they had no say in which towing company
they have to pay the storage fee even
though they had did not have the ability
to have that vehicle taken to to their
own property or to a friend's property
be to be stored so now they're looking
at several hundred even maybe
approaching $1,000 depending on how long
before they get back around if they've
been injured in the hospital it may have
been some time to get a total vehicle
out of storage they do not have the
ability to get that vehicle out of
storage now in current law the towing
company um gives them 14 days generally
with a few exceptions to get their
vehicle until the towing company sells
the vehicle or sells it for scrap um to
to recoup their
costs
um but in the case of having someone not
able to get that vehicle
out the DMV can suspend your driver's
license the driver's license that the
state has sensibly given you by the
virtue of that that you have shown that
you are able to safely drive a vehicle
this is a permit we're given by the
state a privilege were given because
we've shown we are capable of driving a
vehicle that we have the physical health
and ability and the mental acuity to
safely operate a vehicle and yet that is
removed from a person because they were
not able to pay a private towing
company to exacerbate the situation most
police departments use a favored towing
company who then charge more because
they can you don't have a choice it's
not a free market where you get to
choose which toe and company you want to
use you have to go through them so they
can kind of charge whatever they want
and in fact when I was having my
personal vehicle tow this was not this
situation it I my vehicle was just
stalled on the road the police came by
said hey you're on the side of the road
um I'm going to call my preferred I was
on the phone with my preferred mechanic
who was going to send his Towing vehicle
to come get my car and the my mechanic
said don't let them use XYZ company CU
they will charge you three times what we
will charge you what anyone charges you
they can because the police use them so
you don't have a choice so now you have
a person who needs to get to work who is
low to moderate income and needs to get
to work not only has their vehicle been
total but now you have removed the state
has removed their driver's license
because of a completely private debt
that they had no choice in in
acquiring so this bill is to Simply
remove that
the towing company can recoup their
costs by selling it for scrap or selling
it if it's still drivable they can
recoup the cost the towing company
chooses to to work with that police um
department so they don't have to accept
those jobs they do because it's
profitable for them to do so and um
because of that I don't think it's fair
to basically put people in effectively a
debtor's prison where they can't even
get to work
because we've removed their actual legal
ability to drive even though they've
they've shown they can operate their
vehicle safely we've removed that
ability because they owed a private
company who they had no choice in having
a debt
with the police did it by
force so the reason this came up that
the way in which this came into law is
we have an abandonment law saying that
the uh DMV can essentially fine you if
you abandon a vcle and then in that
definition of Abandonment they include
not picking up your car at a toe company
which is not abandonment that's you not
being able to afford to get it out of
storage again with a company you had no
choice in choosing and at a location you
had no choice in because most people if
they have a choice will ask for not a
$100 a day storage somewhere that they
will have to find a way to get to that
plate location they would choose to have
it tow to their parking space at their
home but that's not an option for them
so they had no choice in the toe company
no choice in the storage and yet we're
defining that as abandonment as if
somebody just got rid of their car on
the side of the road I don't think it
was fair that we put that under the
definition of Abandonment and then
allowed the DMV to revoke your license
having been nothing but a good driver
revoke your license um on that basis
that you couldn't afford for
that so the National Insurance crime
Bureau this is an organization for over
a 100 years has nationally gone after
insurance fraud um companies that have
kind of prayed on and I this is a weird
thing for me to say but prayed on the
insurance industry by just basically
milking insurance for as much as they
can get they've identified predatory
towing companies they believe that our
current law um is allowing those towing
companies to be predatory basically
using the government mechanism and the
force of the government the strong arm
of the government to extort people into
paying private Towing fees of exorbitant
amounts so the National Insurance crime
Bureau has logged in in support of this
bill because they've identified uh
towing companies across the country that
have been predatory but specifically in
New Hampshire we are allowing them a
legal way to extort customers into
paying them so I've explained the
situation I've explained why the bill is
the way it is um I will say that we can
go in and redefine if you if the
committee so wanted to to amend Define
the um to tweak the definition of
Abandonment um which is a larger
definition that just includes this one
thing but what I've done here is say
look whatever you define as abandonment
you can't revoke the license and um I
think it's incredibly necessary to keep
the the privil VES that we receive from
the government and the workings and our
our ability to interact with the
government separate from our private
debts in fact I think this might be the
only instance I know of where the
government one of the very few I'll say
one of the very few instances I know of
where the government will hold over your
head a privilege that it gives to you
based on your abilities to to do
something um B will hold that privilege
over your head on the basis that you owe
a private company that you had no choice
but to go into debt with
money so with that I'm happy to take
questions oh I will say I've had two
constituents to whom this has happened
one was early when I first got elected
and I didn't really understand what he
was saying and then more recently this
has come to my attention again so this
is something that is actually being
practiced in the real world and I will
agree with you that's not the first time
I've heard of concerns and complaints
about the towing system that we've got
uh any questions from the committee
represent
Taro thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question could you
elaborate at all in this bill concerning
14 what when you say elaborate is there
something in particular you're pointing
to as problematic or needing
clarification
um if I may it's uh just uh what this
paragraph does in effect I don't
understand if you you could enlighten
me mention of an offense under the
provision of this title a hearing where
the driver's reasonable notice of the
possibility of
license for any for any cause not
prohibited in the
previous so basically this was an
existing paragraph and we're saying that
yes you can you can go through the
normal systems you just can't have um a
hearing where the notice is about the
removal of the license that's not going
to be a factor for this particular thing
because we are prohibiting it here in
263 okay thank you yeah and it may be
helpful too when we look at answering
questions because it is a good one uh
it's helpful to take and open up our
books and actually look at the whole
26357 and then overlay this to what's
current cuz now we just see a paragraph
versus the whole chapter a lot of times
it answers itself any other questions
from the committee represent St Clair
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative um do you know of any
other causes from bills from private
companies that the DMV would pull a
license for non-payment none at all in
fact I don't know
anywhere I mean you could get into like
say something like child support where
you kind of owe a private person but
that's kind of a different animal
altogether there's really I mean there's
leans on houses if you don't pay your
contractor but that's it's still a
different animal altogether we don't
this is again this is a privilege that
the state ostensibly bestows on a person
on the basis of they have proven they
are safe to operate a vehicle on the
road that is the only
requirement and we are making that
contingent on owing a private debt to a
private company that you had no choice
in going to debt with in fact the only
people that had a choice was the police
department at the time so there's
there's nowhere else in law that I know
that we do that whatsoever but certainly
not with driver's
licenses thank you further
questions see none thank you oh
representative
pondon thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking a question I'm
just trying to uh because I again it was
stated I don't have the whole RSA here
so I'm trying to understand for example
at what point in the process would the
towing SL Storage Company claim
ownership of the
vehicle in in most cases and they do
make uh extensions for people who are in
cars like if you got like let's say you
were in irq and you were um intoxicated
and you got arrested that night or you
got I don't know if they make an
extension for based on the hospital if
you're in the hospital or not but for
most situations the tolling company has
14 days and if you don't clim claim the
vehicle in 14 days which for some people
is a paycheck period right like they may
not even have that money until the
following paycheck anyway so you have 14
days to claim and if you don't claim now
you can take personal property out of
the vehicle before then but if you don't
claim the vehicle in 14 days they can
sell the vehicle to recoup their costs
and I guess it's a key point because I
think maybe when we were defining
abandonment in statute I can kind of see
some towing company lobbying here going
and this is all here saying or or
speculation on my part saying look how
do we get our money back if we don't
hold something over them but they can
get their money back they can sell the
vehicle even if it's for scrap the cost
of Steel right now is through the roof
so they would certainly get the cost of
the towing and the keeping it on their
property for 14 days back they may not
make a profit off of that so um I can
imagine that's how we end up with the
wording that we currently have I don't
know that any other state actually does
it like this um but yeah 14 days in
general is is how long you have which is
not an exorbitant amount of time for
them to hold something quick
followup followup um so in in in your
scenario of a total vehicle would would
it protect a citizen to utilize the
option of signing over the the total
vehicle to the yard within that 14 days
and thus not we owe these monies is that
a viable option it's only viable if the
towing compan is willing to do that okay
I think again the towing companies in
question largely are the ones that
operate in hand inand with the police
departments and they like my for my
example when my my vehicle was dead on
the side of the road um my mechanic was
going to charge through my AAA 100 bucks
it was only you know just like a couple
miles away the one that the police were
going to go through which didn't accept
AAA um was $300 something dollar so they
can do that because the police are
giving them basically forcible customers
I don't the police told me unless you're
tow truck gets here first I'm not
waiting the my guy is going to take it
and that's what they do in an accident
situation even if it's off to the side
of the road they still use their own now
if they know they're going to sell like
yeah if they'll if sign over the vehicle
that's totaled and um they're going to
get $600 in scrap for it versus I owe
them a
$1,500 they they're going to try to get
their money out of me knowing that the
state will suspend my license and I have
no
choice thank you any other questions
seeing none thank you very
much uh I do not have anybody else
signed up to speak to this okay I
to I was I was going to ask CU I didn't
recognize everybody and I didn't
well I waited for nothing I can't read
your name so go ahead welcome Rick I
Richard yes Richard what's your last
n I've been in New Hampshire good
afternoon sir how are you good I guess
I've been in New Hampshire resident
since 1984 and I've been in New Market
since
1986 um my son my oldest son got in an
accident in Portsmouth approximately a
quarter of a mile from his
home the car got towed to a tow yard in
Portsmouth
and my son was raising two little girls
with their mother in a rented mobile
home and for him at $12 an hour life was
pretty tough to begin with so then he
lost the vehicle that he got in the
accident with and then they took away
his driver's
license my son has not had a driver's
license since
law so I'm the one that brought this to
the attention of
Ellen I don't think it's right that
anybody should have the ability
he had a rather well-paying job prior to
that but then when he got his license
taken away he could only walk to work
and he had limited choices you know
pumping gas washing cars he ended up at
an oil changing location and you know
those jobs are 12 13 $15 an hour how was
he supposed to pay the
$1,500 back to the towing yard at $12 an
girls so I just don't I think it's not
right and then and then he asked to get
that so almost set thank you I got a
question for you so what happened with
the vehicle did the towing company sell
it and yes they did sold it for scrap
okay and so do you have any idea if they
got more or less than what was owed on
the oh I'm sure they got less I'm sure
sure they got less okay because you know
back then it the scrap was like 5600
bucks but the the storage fees had gone
up the last time I looked was
$1,500 that was 9 years ago that was
2016 okay and my kid hasn't had a
driver's license since then okay I'm
just trying to get a little little
information I understand yep thank you
very much and take any other questions
any other
questions sen H uh thank you Mr chairman
thank you for being here today sure yeah
um I'm not sure if I'm prying I hope I'm
not did your son have insurance on the
vehicle no okay no most of the kids that
are making 12 15 bucks an hour they
can't afford two three $4,000 a year for
insurance okay all right thank you no
you have no
insurance representative blondon thank
you Mr chair and thank you for attending
today sir just a quick question um this
towing company or any other towing
companies are you where can they charge
interest on this past due debt as well
I'm not aware okay I'm not aware thank
you looks like we got some work for us
on this one anybody else from the
committee seeing thank you very much all
right thank you um I know the director
is out of state but this is certainly
one I would have liked to have heard
from the Department of Motor
Vehicles uh is there anybody here from
the Department of Motor Vehicles that
this if it's not your wheelhouse we can
later it's up to you I'm not trying to
I know what we're going to do on this
this
sure just again for the record alen Reed
Rockingham 10 and I failed to mention
that this would also reinstate the
licenses for anyone who's had their
license revoked on this cause solely on
this cause so anyone who's currently
without a license would get their
license back if this passes as written
I'm happy to help with amending though
thank
you sure representative Hill thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking my
question do you have any idea how many
that entails how many I don't and that
would be a question for I think DMV to
answer thank
you okay um anybody else all right thank
you all right I'm G to close the public
hearing not seeing anybody else wishing
to speak on H Bill 4
14 and to the committee um again I would
have lik to have heard somebody who from
the right Department from the motor
director of Motor Vehicle from Motor
Vehicles even though we don't do a lot
of subcommittees in this this this
committee I think this bill is going
right down that Avenue we'll talk about
that later so
um next up actually we are on time we're
a little behind give us a couple minutes
e
okay being 128 I'm going to open up the
public hearing on House Bill 439 FN
relative to non-driving related
violations and driver's license
suspensions uh chair recognizes the
prime sponsor representative
ve good afternoon chairman Walsh and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Dan ve I represent Hillsboro
34 in Amherst uh thank you for the
opportunity to present HB 439 which
seeks to end the suspension of driver's
licenses for non-driving related
violations this bill is about fairness
economic mobility and ensuring that our
traffic laws focus on Public Safety
rather than debt
collection right now thousands of New
Hampshire residents lose their driver's
license every year not because because
of unsafe driving but because they were
unable to pay court fines or
administrative fees unrelated to any
motor vehicle offense let me be clear
this is not about letting dangerous
drivers off the hook this bill does not
change any existing laws regarding
license suspension for DUI reckless
driving or other public safety
violations it only applies to cases
where a person's license is suspended
solely due to the inability to pay a
financial penalty that has nothing to do
with their driving behavior the simple
truth is taking away a person's ability
to drive because of unpaid fines makes
it harder for them to work support their
families and pay off their debt instead
of helping people get back on their feet
we're pushing them further into a cycle
of economic hardship license suspensions
trap people in a cycle of poverty many
people need their cars to work if they
can't drive they may lose their job if
they lose their job they fall further
behind on their fines and other bills a
2019 study by the American Association
of Motor Vehicle administrators found
that 75% of suspended drivers continue
to to drive not because they want to
break the law but because they have no
other way to get to work medical
appointments or care for their
families suspensions for non-payment
don't improve Public Safety the current
law treats an inability to pay a fine
the same as a reckless driving or DUI
offense even though they have nothing in
common license suspensions should be
used for Dangerous drivers not as a tool
for debt collection the burden falls
disproportionally on lower income
residents wealthier individuals can pay
Their fines immediately while lower
income individuals struggle leading to a
suspension and a downward spiral studies
from states that have ended debt based
suspensions such as California and
Virginia show that removing these
suspensions allows more people to work
pay their debts and contribute to the
economy some may ask doesn't the state
get generate revenue from the
suspensions yes legislative budget
assistant estimates that HB 439 will
result in a revenue decrease of about
$955,000 per year due to l reinst fees
which is a lot of reinstatement
fees however in consider these factors
administrative cost offset revenue
losses the DMV processes tens of
thousands of license suspensions each
year a significant administrative burden
by ending non-ri driver related
suspensions DMV will save time and
resources allowing them to focus more on
pressing traffic safety concerns keeping
people employed boosts economic growth
when people lose their jobs due to
license suspension they may end up on
public assistance which increases State
costs keeping people licensed and
working means they contribute to the
economy pay Their fines and support
their families a better long-term
Financial outcome for the state New
Hampshire is not alone in this reform
we're not the first state to consider
ending debt based drivers Su license
suspensions California Virginia Montana
and West Virginia have already limited
license suspensions for unpaid fees
Maine and Massachusetts have taken
similar steps to ensure that driver's
licenses are suspended only for traffic
safety violations these states have seen
positive outcomes including more people
staying employed and repaying their
debts without compromising Public Safety
HB 439 is a common sense reform that
ensures license suspensions are used to
promote Public Safety and not punish
financial
hardship that's all I have and I will
take questions thank you sir questions
from the
committee representative London thank
you Mr chair and thank you
representative
um I'm not adverse to this uh just to
preface I represent Nashua uh density
populated
municipality and uh we've got strict
non-moving
violations with this
legislation the current action from what
I see from inner city is a complete
disregard of non-moving
violations uh ripping up tickets so
on what recourse would there be for the
person that continually blocks a hydrant
or driveways on a continual basis rips
up the tickets what recourse is there to
correct this action if we this if our
current legislation is not in
place you want the penalty be to be
consistent with the violation you would
I can't say what would be the best I'm
you know I'd have to research that kind
of violation but I suppose Towing their
car and uh going into debt Collections
and other u means like that would be the
best process um suspending somebody's
life
for non-driving violations is you know
like I said it creates a a poor cycle
and it's punishes people for things that
aren't related to to the crime they
committed
so thank you Mr chair any other
questions Johnson thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for taking my question
does this bill um have any overlap with
the bill we just heard HB 414 FN not
directly this this um has more to do
with unpaid unrelated fines for uh that
for other things other than motor
vehicle
violations um such as uh suspensions for
unpaid fines uh license suspension for
defaulting on court payments um fines
for for violations in other states for
elating fines that you know maybe in
Massachusetts or Maine or somewhere else
in the country that has reciprocity with
New
Hampshire is this bill based on House
Bill 650 from last term it I don't know
um I had help drafting it from
representative Sher all right um okay
any other
questions representative pataro thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question so when am am I to assume that
when a suspension takes place the final
Arbiter of that is the
DMV the DMV receives some sort of notice
that the license holder is in debt and
thus they suspend the license yeah I I
imagine there's some kind of a process
that comes down from the courts um that
allows a DMB to execute that that order
to suspend the license I don't know if
they have the discretion on their own
may may I re ask the question did I you
can modify it I mean um in other words
it would only be the courts that is
sending the DMV these notices right okay
thank you and I will help you represent
pataro this is similar to House Bill 650
from last year we've been told that it's
been used at the very last resort as a
very last resort but we will once again
try to get some testimony from the
Department of motive vehicles on this as
well any other questions representative
Fox thank you Mr
chairman do you have any uh any numbers
representative on
uh how many license suspensions are
current uh due to non-payment of other
fines uh I don't have it directly
accessible accessible to me right now
but uh I believe it's over 14,000 a year
license
suspensions thank you anybody
else representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question um I'm assuming the process is
there a hearing um uh is it left up to
the director is there any leeway or is
this a uh a a mandatory um suspension
that we're talking about I I think once
it comes down from the court it's it's
mandatory for the DMV to follow through
you all right anybody else seeing none
thank you very
much uh next up Cher represent bu share
Bill thank you Mr chair I'm
representative bu sh uh from Rockingham
District
26 uh also known as Portsmouth ward 3 um
not incidentally I am uh I'm also a
elected Police Commissioner in uh
Portsmouth um
I uh representative a um covered a lot
of what I uh I was going to talk about
uh not surprisingly um and I have I
think it's been circulated written
testimony on this so I I want to
emphasize uh a couple things really
uh to address
representative I'm going to butcher your
name but
pandon ah not
that um to answer your question um there
are other as I as I addressed in my
written
testimony there are other mechanisms
already in place for one people who are
have not paid their fine or have failed
to pay their fine and two separately for
people who have not shown up for court
for people who have not shown up for
court uh the bail system under 597 uh
col 7 uh we've been working on that for
a number of years to deal with failures
to appear and it's a much more targeted
uh uh way of dealing with people who
don't show up for court um it and it you
know the mechanisms that are there um
are are better than suspending
somebody's license uh for the obvious
reason of uh to be a little snarky about
it um really doesn't make sense to
suspend someone's license and make it
harder for for them to show up for court
by not having a license um uh and uh the
same the same is true with suspending uh
somebody's license for a failure to pay
a fine at least with a certain group of
people those who uh what I identify in
my written testimony those people who
who don't even have the luxury of living
paycheck to paycheck um suspending their
license for not paying a fine that they
may be struggling to pay makes it harder
for them to go to a job makes it harder
for them to go to a job interview um
it's it's in that sense it's it's like
using a sledgehammer when an actual
Hammer would work and and and as I
described the bail system is there it's
a very well uh developed system AKA
hammer for people who don't show up for
court for people who don't pay their
fine uh there is uh what what was put in
place uh maybe five years ago or so um
RSA
604a colon
2-f which is referred to in my uh
written
testimony that is a mechanism where the
court can call into court somebody who
has failed to pay a fine and they can
appoint them a lawyer uh and then they
can they they're notified that if they
that the hearing is whether they can
afford to pay their fine or not whether
they have an ability to pay their fine
if the court finds that they have an
ability to pay the fine and haven't paid
their fine then the court can jail the
person uh at the rate of $100 a day uh
until their fine is quote unquote paid
off uh if the court finds that they do
not have the ability to pay the fine uh
then the court can uh try other
mechanisms they can uh try an extended f
payment uh process they can suspend the
fine uh that that it can be worked
through uh with the court how to deal
with somebody who is in has a financial
condition um that really doesn't allow
them to pay the fine um uh again that's
a very effective Hammer um and rather
than this uh license suspension which is
a sledgehammer that's ill directed now
the legislation very
clearly identifies that this doesn't
apply to the majority the most moving
violations uh representative Miller uh
had had a brief chat with him uh before
he left um and he he raised a uh a
moving violation that didn't seem to be
included I'm more than willing to work
with the uh with the committee and
represent of Miller in particular if
anybody thinks there are moving
violations that should be included in
addition the ones that are already here
the more serious moving violations more
than willing uh to work with the
committee uh on that I will also note
um that uh I spoke with a uh I I
communicated with a representative from
uh uh Americans for Prosperity uh Sarah
Scott uh and they are supportive I think
they've identified their support online
she was unable to be here she has the
flu uh but they supportive of of HB
439 um uh I think again it's it makes
sense
to change the system to the extent we're
not
using license
suspension for areas where there's other
mechanisms in place number one and
number two where license
suspension in a in a sense contradicts
what we want to have happen uh we want
people to pay Their fines so we want
them to go to work uh we want people to
show up for court so we wanted to have a
car um it in that sense it's time
to reduce our Reliance on license
suspension as the qall to getting things
to happen um you know I historically the
court system has used the you know they
send out a letter and threaten PE the
people who haven't paid their fine if
you don't pay your fine we're going to
suspend your license and that they get
some response on that not understandably
but they can now send it they they
haven't but they could easily send out a
letter said if you don't pay your fine
we're going to have a hearing to decide
whether you serve your fine off at $100
a day I mean that's as good a threat as
license suspension um and it's still uh
it it it it protects those who really do
have financial difficulty um
uh more than willing to take
questions thank you would you believe I
think I'd rather lose my LC to go to
jail working up 100 bucks a day but
that's just me well you know I've I had
um people uh I used to be a public
defender and and uh some people would
rather pay off their fine by at back
then it was 50 bucks a day so it people
make interesting choices question for
you you said uh RSA 604
a2f U did you say it was recently ified
and used more uh that was uh
past boy seven or eight years ago long
ago okay and I because where I was going
with this is if they're relying more on
604 how many times is the suspension
actually been used since then so I I
don't know I haven't been we haven't
been able to it's hard to my
understanding and I won't speak for
motor vehicles but my understanding is
it's hard to separate at out what the
license suspensions were I and something
I forgot to say I will also note there's
a bill pending in front of house
criminal justice of which I'm a member
um to give Motor Vehicles more time M
vle Department Department of Safety more
time to uh for people to pay Their fines
right now it's a maximum of 30 days but
the
bill extends that to 90 days um so
there's this is a a multi-pronged effort
to to to to find some other mechanisms
to address a real problem fair enough
thank you any other questions from the
committee representative pataro thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question um just so uh understand
correctly the current uh ver format
version of the bill is just for the
situation of people um not paying fines
and or not showing up for court or not
showing up for court and then somebody
else you and you said you were also
willing to work on something to add
non-moving violations no to add apparent
uh representative Miller identified a
another moving violation that wasn't
included on the list uh in uh
439 um uh uh which was unintentional on
439 talks about um RSA
26579 26582 Etc has that list those are
all moving violations uh relate to
moving violations and representative
Miller identified another uh passing a
school bus that is a moving violation
that's not on that list and we're more
if anybody can think of any other moving
violations not included on the list in
HB 439 that should be added more more
thank you for that thanks anybody else
from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much thank you uh I have nobody else
signed up to speak to House Bill
439 including nobody from the Department
of Motor Vehicles I guess we're going to
have to do some some information
abstraction on this one as well did you
have
something okay come on up and I need you
right
I chair recognizes Brandy what's your
last
name what is it CA okay Brandy cassa
from the Department of Motor Vehicles uh
not taking a position on the bill it
seems uh all yours welcome thank you
chair thank you committee members um I
my name is Brandy CID I'm the
administrator of the Bureau of financial
responsibilities that oversees
suspensions and revocations I'm here to
answer any questions you might have
related to the bill that's
proposed okay U any questions from the
committee
some
guys thank you Mr chair ma'am so I know
of a case where somebody had a violation
they got mailed their their fine or
their court hearing didn't get it in the
mail and then the next time they even
found out about it it was when they were
being arrested for driving with under a
suspended license um I guess my question
is what is the requirement to ensure
that somebody has been notified before
their license is revoked and a bench
warrant is put out
are you so to clarify the question are
you speaking of citations served in hand
or Court's
notification uh either or both in this
case the citation was served by hand and
then and then you know the guy basically
put the citation down on a thing and
forgot about it and you know what what's
what's going on to notify people even if
it's a Serb
notification if it is a served enhanced
um citation there's instructions on the
back of the citation of how to address
um how you can pay or enter a plea of
not guilty um after 30 days of unpay
that citation does go into a default of
which a notice of default is sent with
the fee including the $50 administrative
fee that's assessed at that time along
with the date of suspension um if no
action is no plea is entered on that
citation and um no other notices will be
sent after that notice of default so DMV
mails to the record the the address
file
sir you got follow up thank you so if
somebody's license is suspended they're
notified One Time by mail and they don't
get it for some reason have we just
created a repeat offender by not
adequately
notifying I can't answer that question
um any other
questions representative thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question um one of the previous people
who um uh gave testimony mentioned that
there are
14,000 suspensions out there can you um
confirm that number and also speak to
another notion that it's difficult to
sort through the reasons for all those
suspensions okay so I can speak to the
numbers that we received in 201 23 uh
when this fiscal note was written um we
received approximately 45,000 defaults
at the DMV
um relative to what would be allowed for
default in this law which is the DWI
aggravated DWI Reckless operation of
boat and reckless driving um 3500 of
those
can you clarify that one more time I
guess just relative to this
bill how many are not related to any
motor vehicle violations is there any
way I do not have that okay is there any
way you could find that yeah okay thank
you anybody else from the
committee not seeing none thank you
thank you I have nobody else signed to
speak on signed up to speak on House
Bill 439
nobody jumping up either with that I'll
close the public
hearing we have a few minutes to kill
we'll be going into executive session
it's scheduled for two will probably be
a little late I know we've got to have a
then
e
uh I'm not going to take them up today
House Bill 209 being one of
them and the other one
is excuse
me
298 those two we have amendments we have
information uh just not where we want to
be yet uh it's not even worthy of a
debate yet so we're going to I'm not
going to take those up today and I re
260 that being said I will open up you
have that I will open up the executive
session on House
sheet too many papers here uh I'm going
to open up the executive session on
House Bill uh 119 FN allowing rental
companies applying to register rental
Fleet to choose New Hampshire as a base
jurisdiction under the international
registration plan also known as IRP
chair recognizes representative Gorski
for a motion thank you Mr chair uh my
motion is itl for HB
1119 second um it's been moved and
second by was that representative Hill
sure representative Hill K to speak to
your motion sir I do thank you um when
we heard testimony on this bill we we
listened and heard from the
DMV and they basically said that this
bill already the companies already have
the capability that this bill is
proposing um and that that's that the
bill really doesn't change anything so
based on that I just don't think this
bill is really necessary so that's why I
think we should itl this
bill anybody else from the
committee seeing none I'll ask the clerk
to call the roll when she's ready the
motion is inexpedient to legislate
Vice chairman Gorski yes the clerk votes
yes representative Hill yes
representative Boyd yes representative
mataro yes representative Coker yes
repes representative gas yes
representative Hamlin yes representative
Sykes yes representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox yes representative
Veo yes representative Johnson yes
representative pondon yes representative
Miller yes and chairman Walsh
yes all right our recommendation of 160
inexpedient the legisl is
adopted this one can go on consent if
you see F did I hear consent second it
second on on consent representative
Coker no objections to consent seeing
none that's where it'll go we'll close
exzac session on
119 um few minutes to reset House Field
one oh you you can have as many as you
that
yeah let me know when you're ready I'm
ready all right I'll open up the
executive session on House Bill 182 have
been prohibiting electric vehicles and
commercial parking
garages is there a
motion I see representative
gon I Motion in expedient to legislate
on House Bill
182 uh in expedient to legislate is the
motion is there a second
represent Miller times says
second I had to do it care to speak to
your motion sir yes
sir so the biggest issues that I had
with this bill is it's written come down
to a couple of things one of them is
encroachment into private properties um
private businesses and Private Affairs
um there are companies major Employers
in the state who spent millions of
dollars to put charging stations in
their own garages and for us to pass a
law that tells them that that investment
is a bad investment is a move Point um
it's it's an encroachment on their
rights as Property Owners if there are
products being given to the market that
are so unsafe that they require us to
treat them differently by law we need to
be sending those back to the
manufacturers to get a safer product not
punishing people who are trying to move
to a different product um there was talk
of an amendment to restricted under
dwellings uh I think that could have
been something that could have been
talked about but I just even then those
are privately owned um oftentimes and I
think this is an overreach of government
into people's private
property anybody else from the committee
thank you
sir anybody
else okay uh personally I would have
preferred to see n retain would have
worked we we do have a commission
working on um some of the adverse
effects of of um electric I mean um ion
batteries
but I I do Point well taken um I guess
I'll leave it at that no with nobody
else from the committee here I am
stuttering I'll ask the clerk to call
when she's ready uh the motion on the
floor isn't expedient to
legislate Vice chairman gor yes clerk
votes yes representative Hill yes
representative Boyd yes representative
ataro yes representative Coker yes
representative G yes representative
Hamlin yes representative Sykes yes
representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox yes representative
auu yes representative Johnson yes
representative hondon yes representative
Miller yes and chairman Walsh yes 16 to
zero
second um our adop our recommendation of
inexpedient legislate is adopted 160 I
heard consent who was that
representative Miller is there second
for
consent Coker uh no objections seeing
none consent it is I'll close the
executive session on House Bill
182 209 we're taking up next week
hopefully we'll go into house bill 239
a
I'll open up the executive session on
House Bill 239 FN defining and enabling
Lane
filtering uh I'll open it up to the
floor for a motion I have nobody signed
it why not
itl representative CER moves inexpedient
the legislator is there second second
seconded by representative Crawford here
to speak your motion sir um I think
there's some issues that were brought up
by this bill but the bill as written
just is is a little too rough and uh
really can't be salvaged
and basically just creates more
questions and safety issues than uh what
needs to be for what we think there
might be a use for something like this
committee so I was really hoping that
this could uh could be something that
would be retained because the two
biggest arguments that I heard um were a
lack of education and by retaining it we
could address the education portion and
then some writing changes in terms of
whether or not you know breakdown Lane
use in certain applications or you know
uh CLE cleaning up some of the writing I
really don't think this is a baby out
with the bathwater issue um the other
complaint that I heard was that other
states aren't doing it but I know that
Connecticut is hearing similar
legislation as we speak um and I believe
there's similar legislation proposed in
the state of Maine so where in New
Hampshire is trying to lead the way I
think that we'd be better off to retain
this and actually start focusing on the
education Dynamic of bringing it here
because it's going to come here one way
or another sooner or
later anybody else from the committee
represent St
Clair thank you I I
um I hope that we uh do take this up
again with a different Bill uh in the
next next year it'll just be different a
different enough so that's all thank
you anybody
else um I'll chime in just for a moment
um I've been riding on the street for a
long time I understand we have an issue
with distraction and with possibly
autonomous vehicles someday possibly
causing a lot more rear and crashes so I
get it uh but the way this bill was
written and some of the other unintended
consequences of The Way It Was Written I
just couldn't
support I don't I did not talk to you uh
in our break but I in terms of whether
we should retain this or an expedient to
legislate uh I also did talk with the
speaker who does determine gerain this
uh and this bill was silent on breakdown
Lane use so he's told me that that would
be something non- gerain enough to have
a separate bill in our second year
without any issue so you're right this
is not the baby out with the bath water
even with the itl uh this will be coming
back um I guess I'll leave at that I
think you know talking about breakdown
use does have some Merit because I think
that is a real possibility of being
solved so with nobody else to speak to
the bill I'll ask the clerk to call the
role when she's ready the motion is
legislate Vice chairman M Gorski yes
clerk votes yes representative Hill yes
representative Boyd yes representative
pataro
yes representative Coker yes
representative G no representative
Hamlin yes representative
Sykes yes representative
Sinclair yes representative
Fox yes representative ve yes
representative Johnson yes
representative pandon yes representative
Miller yes and represent U chairman
Walsh yes 15 to one
our recommendation of inexpedient to
legislate is adopted 15 to1 this is
still worthy of consent if there's no
objection representative gon up to you
I'm not okay so do I have a motion
what's
that well if
you if you object
the no it's G be it's goingon to be a
you're not
wasting um who officially took the
motion for consent Coker and a second
anybody pataro uh with no objections
thank you I'll close the executive
session on House Bill
239 uh a few minutes to reset we will go
into house bill 260 you should have an
amendment if you don't have the
amendment um I believe representative
beay had some
I I don't know if I make it this 260 I
think you might have stayed on your di
them we got them coming around for v no
they got way late at the head of the
got I explain that whole end of the
building whatever
thank
back can you put these on the
okay I'm going to open up the EXA
executive session on House Bill 260 FN
creating commemorative license plate
commemorative license plate celebra in
250th anniversary of Bunker
Hill um chair recognizes representative
be for a motion thank you Mr chairman I
move ought to pass on hb26
FN ought to pass have been moved
represent guys in seconds care to speak
in motion sir actually no the bill is
open for further Amendment chair
recognizes representative V thank you Mr
chairman I move uh Amendment uh
139h to hb26
FM have a second for the amendment
representative Hamlin care to speak to
the amendment sir yes thank you um when
this bill was uh introduced to us by
representative Pearson uh I thought it
was a good idea to command Mar Bunker
Hill but since we're already in 2025 and
the Battle of Bunker Hill took place in
2025 it kind of uh made it a little less
relevant for us because we wouldn't have
as much time to to enjoy the the plates
and to get the process going and get the
place designed and distributed so um I
suggested making it the 250th
anniversary of the American of American
independence which is you know um the
Declaration of Independence and New
Hampshire was the first state to uh to
declare independence from the crown so
it's very extremely relevant and it's
got a much broader appeal um so I put
through this this amendment which um
takes care of a couple things that the
DMV asked for which is setting a a fee
and a distribution process for the
plates and the rest will go through uh
processes thank you sir anybody else
representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman um I have I guess one question
um it appears that we're only
getting the front license place
but I see the um wording that says the
price for the plates shall be 25 and and
I'm wondering what if in fact we're only
getting
one
um and and why would we only get one why
would we not make it a cover plate I
guess for
both that's
all
answer the second one which is the
commemorative plate statute only deals
with the front plate right um it's even
though our cover plates are in the same
chapter of lots a different paragraph
we're
allowed both front and rear that's why
we have to have a you know at least
noticed on our registrations or nowadays
they use a document separate document
these don't need that uh and it's also
if you'll notice uh repealed um on July
4th 2027 they're only good for the
year let's read this again though and
the display of said plates and rep place
of the front license plate on
vehicles yeah I don't I
don't plates and the display of said
plates I think it's talking about the
plates in general not just the ones you
get how I read
it that
well
plates yeah5
it I it it also says they rather than it
for shall be distributed I think this is
the plates cost $25 each and they
broadly will be distributed by the DMV
to people who buy them yeah I think it's
just referring to the plates I get I I'm
a stickler on like that too but this one
doesn't strike me as yeah I understand
the question but I don't know if it's a
large
enough misunderstanding that needs to be
changed or if it can be done and
enrolled I was Bill amendments this
would would
be my opinion Mr chairman is that this
would be um if there is an issue and I
don't believe that there is but if there
were an issue it it's such a such a
minor point that it would be could be
corrected in enrolled uh Bill process
and we could bring that to the attention
of the the clerk if
necessary I am on the enrolled bills
committee so I probably could uh I just
it just struck me here that it could be
read either way and I didn't know if it
was something
that was a simple fix or not or
necessary that's all I think we're
covered in the one line on 13 where it
said the display of said plates in place
of the front license plates on vehicles
should cover us that's just my
opinion anybody else on the amendment
question of the chair what what's the
enrolled Bill committee rolled Bill
committee representative Hills on it
I'll let him explain in detail um it's
after everything has passed um and
before but before it gets signed off on
by the um Senate President the speaker
the um Secretary of State and the
governor um they go through just to make
sure there's no conflicts here and there
or crossing keys starting eyes all of
that stuff and and you're just
correcting things like this um that's
all just a procedural thing thank you
some again as simple as cleaning up the
grammar sometimes but again and I think
this Falls there because of the fact
that it deals with front license plates
only by by by description so anybody
else on the amendment I think we're good
to go with it seeing none um all those
in favor of adop in Amendment 0139 H say
I I I oppose nay so the amendment is
adopted the motion on the floor is ought
to pass as adopted care to speak any
more de your motion no I think the the
amendment is Bill now so seeing none
nobody else representative St
Clair thank you Mr
chair I I uh I get the feeling is going
to pass but I am a little confused maybe
uh because of the arguments that people
had on a bill to allow only one license
plate on antique vehicles or specialty
Vehicles because of the uh fear of uh I
guess some lost Revenue with the
tolls uh police just freaking out
because a vehicle went by and they could
only grab the front plate not the rear
plate etc etc and yet here we are
putting a license plate allowing only
one license plate on vehicles in the
state of New Hampshire for a whole year
so I uh I hope everybody remembers this
because I have a feeling there could be
a bill again next year uh again asking
us to allow only a real license plate on
specialty cars or cars that don't come
with a indentation for a license plate
um you know had a lot of discussion on
that so that's all thank you very much
very astute representative s clear
actually this was part of the argument
last time we had that bill and it was
part of the justification and I don't
disagree with
you um actually to be honest I was
surprised we didn't see one of those
bills this year um but that being said
anybody
else I saw
represent thank you Mr chair just for
clarification this is not precedent
setting because I know in Nashville had
at sues Centennial we sold plates for
the front so it's not precedent setting
it is for a year and hopefully it will
generate some much needed revenue for
DOT so thank you represent
SES i' um I'd like to actually thank
representative St Clair for reminding me
of uh previous positions that I have
taken and um I I was inclined to think
that this was somewhat benign but based
on his reminder which is quite valid I I
bill Mr Cherry it's nice to see people
being
consistent representative G so uh my
honorable colleague over here points out
that this could be the gateway to people
actually having freedom of expression
with the front of their vehicles
individual ual freedom of expression
with the front of their vehicles I
support it we're getting up the context
of the bill has
amended representative Fox did you have
your hands up I did I just wanted to
thank representative St Clair as well
and ditto what representative Sykes
said I'm I'm sorry um I I missed the
point that my colleague represented St
Clair said Can someone walk me through
that again with the front plate what
I'll
okay so in the actually you weren't here
welcome back for the last couple of
terms or at least two year uh I forget
how many years at least twice we've seen
attempts to eliminate the front license
plate on personal Motor Vehicles which
and they failed both
times and the argument was that we
couldn't do without the front license
plate because we lose whole revenues
it's not good for the department of
safety using their plate readers etc etc
etc so he was just pointing out the
irony that we said we need that front
plate so importantly in the past why
should we give up the front plate when
we have a commemorative plate for the
250th anniversary of the United
States just drawing
a I want to thank him for for instilling
this debate on what I thought was a very
simple I'm I'm I'm sorry so the Comm
ative plate isn't going to have the
regist the license plate number on it no
it won't no and these the this chapter
he's been in statute for a long time you
see a lot of towns using this on their
on their anniversaries or bicentennials
they're only good for a year they have
are cover plate you still have to have
your vehicle registered so it's not like
the Moose sticker it's a no no it is a
thank you purchased purchased
individually and okay hold on
representative
crawfords so just remember this plate is
for a year
plus I'd love to say it's going to you
know get a lot of Revenue but how many
are we going to sell there aren't going
to be loads of thousands of people with
this in New Hampshire with this plate oh
we do I'm buy I don't think so
yeah anybody else from the committee I
just quickly point out that this does
come with some Revenue it doesn't cost
$25 to generate these plates so there
will be some Revenue coming back to the
the state and going to the cause listed
so anybody else from the committee who's
in the office oh we lost a couple of
people here oh no we didn't I
did no we don't have H actually that's a
crate back there we may we may have
one anybody else did I see a hand over
here here no all right we're almost done
we're almost done beating this one to
death representative Hamlin uh thank you
um so we're talking about the front
plate fine but nothing is mentioned to
exclude motorcycles from this
bill whereas they only use a rear plate
so they are not allowed to express their
independence these are passenger vehicle
plates they're a different size this
doesn't apply to motor V motorcycles
okay a they don't have two plates and B
they're much smaller not relative so we
won't be able to get a cover plate on
the rear of our motorcycle either okay
thank
you you you know there's probably
nothing to prevent you from buying one
and fixing it to your forks though to be
you yeah anybody else I think we've had
enough fun with this one all right I'll
ask the clerk to call the when she's
ready the motion on the floor is ought
to pass is
amended Vice chairman Gorski yes the
clerk votes yes representative Hill no
representative Boyd yes representative
patara yes representative Koker yes
representative Gea yes representative
Hamlin yes representative
Sykes no representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox no representative a
yes representative Johnson
no representative pondon yes
our recommendation of a to passes
amended is adopted 12 to 4 this will be
going on the regular calendar I am
looking for volunteers for the floor
one and will there be a Minority
Report
Charlie so that being said I'll close
the executive session on House Bill 260
287 Charlie swung four votes right there
that's
okay I'll open up the executive
session I'll open up the executive
session on House Bill
287 uh requiring police departments to
provide fire departments with certain
motorist personal and insurance
information following a motor vehicle
incident um chair recognizes
representative Gorski thank you Mr
chairman uh my motion is for itl on HP
287 motion is in expedient the
legislator is there a
second seconded by representative hlin G
to speak to your motion sir I do thank
you Mr chairman um you know when we were
hearing the testimony in this whole this
whole
bill I don't know if it's the Executive
coaching me but listening to this was
like they want us to legislate
communication between departments and I
just this is something that I think you
just kind of work it out and figure it
out I'm really not a big fan of creating
a bill in a law that says You must talk
to each other so based on that I just
can't support this and that's why I say
itl on this
bill anybody else from the committee
representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman first off I need to apologize
to the committee the fellow that I
talked with um also apologized to me and
said it's not Hippa it was Foya that and
he said I always get that mixed up but
it also um is part of the and I'll ask
the chair for the reminder of the state
law it is is what the Privacy yeah I'm
you had to ask me the actual Acron have
Acron it's driver privacy driver Privacy
Act would be good enough for
conversation driver Privacy Act um which
is what my chief of police in Northfield
um which was the impetus for the entire
Bill and and he said under that um it
doesn't list the fire department is who
he can share information
with he turned around and asked the
Chief of Police Association which he
belongs to for their opinion and they
came back to him and said we don't care
so um he's he has asked me to support it
he thinks it's important but he said the
chiefs of police do not so or don't care
so um for that reason I'm going to um
vote on to but uh but that's my summary
of past
events anybody else from the committee
representative
SES yeah so um I I'm also will vote
against the itl motion only because I
felt that there was a no harm no foul
aspect to this bill and that
um sometimes a little guidance to help
people move to do the right thing is not
and there's no I I don't see any any
reason why we shouldn't be able to uh
help the small volunteer fire
departments who may not have the total
resources necessary to gain this
information when they they should be
able to
so against them against the itl yeah and
and if if we get to that point then I
OTP anybody else in the
commit um I saw him first I'm sorry
represent Miller yeah sorry just quick
clarification what was the citation that
you were saying affected the sharing
from the police to the fire
department it's the one we can't think
of um you thought it was 264 something
it's
26144 thank
you and it's motor vehicle records and
certification uh 2614 and it's all about
privacy of the information particularly
that's that's possessed by agency
uh and again this is a direct change to
I say
26014 actually Roman
7 um that's added and I still have to
question why it wasn't there to begin
with from what I understand right now
there's nothing to prevent the fire
department from going over to the
individual to get the information
because it's not a violation of this law
when the owner gives them the
information it's just what this
currently it's always been understood
and protected that once an agency has
personal and private information that
they keep it if they're allowed to have
it so um that's where we are on that
anybody else on the committee any
representative Fox thank you Mr chairman
I asked that question myself and and
uh the answer that I received is the
fire department doesn't generally have
the information to go to the person
directly so after the fact after an
event where the fire department has
shown up spread their kitty litter or
whatever they've done um they don't stop
and ask the people involved for their
name and address and information the
police department does
that so there in lies the issue with
them going directly because they can go
directly if they have the information
the name the phone number and and um
insurance
information may I ask another just an
another question I have is
um representative PR was asked about the
services from the fire department that
are billable does anybody did anybody
get a list of those Services other than
the kitty litter that we know about I
did not receive
anything it's just m but but but there
in lies the question and that's the one
we have to ask answer ourselves today is
the Speedy dry justifiably another
reason for the sharing of per people's
personal information outside of what's
currently written in law this in other
words makes one more exception to it
being spread and by who so that's that's
really the question we're
asking and representative Hill so I
thought representative PR did mention
that they're probably not going to get
this information for the speedy dry um
but if they had to um um arrange the
environmental
straw tubes whatever those are called um
which are fairly expensive that that's
what they were looking for is that kind
of information I think that was what was
used in this particular accident as a
matter of
fact you on that if I remember correctly
there it did come up in our conversation
that there could be certain
circumstances when the accident is under
investigation and it certainly wouldn't
be wise for police to be sharing any of
the information um you know a lot of
things we don't know what goes on in
that course
so again there had to have been a reason
why it wasn't in inserted the first time
so just I'll leave it at that anybody
else from the
committee see amen I'll ask the clerk to
call the role when she's ready the
motion on the floor on House Bill
287 is inexpedient to
legislate I chairman Gorski
yes the clerk votes yes representative
Hill no representative Boyd yes
representative
pataro yes representative Coker
no representative um G yes
representative Hamlin yes representative
Sykes no representative Sinclair no
yes representative a no representative
Johnson yes Representative pandon no
representative
Miller
no and chairman Walsh I have no idea
what the number is
yes we'll know in a
minute nine
yeses and seven NOS
recommendation of inexpedient to
legislators adopted 9-7 regular calendar
it will
be um I'll close the executive session
on
287 um minority
reports okay I'll let you know yeah let
me know both sides
actually
um 298 we're holding up on one more for
today a few minutes to reset oh two more
um next one up will be House Bill
612 and the other one we're going to
take up is one we heard
today I would have liked to have done
more but I'm just
just but I think uh what we get through
will be enough for today we will also be
taking up House Bill 368 prohibiting
smoking and ecigarettes and Motor
all right I'll open up the executive
session on House Bill 62 FN enabling the
Division of Motor Vehicles to create
temporary traditional Li uh driver's
license for youth operators about to
turn 21 chair recognizes representative
Au for a motion thank Mr chairman I move
autopass on HB 612 FN autopass has been
moved as our second representative St
CLA I saw him first can to speak to your
motion sir yes thank you uh this bill
helps a lot of young people who are
transitioning to a standard operator
license which is the horizontally
oriented license um it helps them avoid
the hassle of getting the vertical the
vertical youth operator license if they
try if they have to uh renew ahead of
time or having to wait until their
birthday to get the horizontal licensees
it also helps uh alleviate some of the
administrative burden on the DMV by
spreading out the demand for new
licenses and removing the need to issue
duplicate licenses when the young people
inevitably come back with their vertical
licenses to get the horizontal duplicate
grown-ups thank you sir anybody else
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the rooll when she's ready the motion is
ought to pass on House Bill 612 Vice
chairman Gorski yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes representative
Boyd yes representative pataro yes
representative Coker yes representative
um G yes representative Hamlin yes
representative Sykes yes representative
Sinclair yes representative Fox yes
representative a yes representative
Johnson yes representative Pon yes
representative Miller yes and chairman
Walsh yes cons consent
[Music]
160 he's catching on isn't he seems to
be uh our our recommendation of the pass
is adopted 160 consent been moved by
representative gson then second
representative St Clair no objection to
consent Noe seeing none consent it
is that closes the executive session on
House Bill 612 as I said few minutes to
e
all right I'll open up the executive
session on H Bill
368 prohibiting smoking in ecigarettes
and Motor Vehicles when a passenger is
under 16 years of age can I get a motion
representative
pataro I move itl from this bill in
expedient the
legislative inexpedient the legislator
has been moved seconded by
representative gon care to speak your
motion
sir thank you Mr chair um this
particular bill just isn't needed
now okay anybody else in the committee
represent
G this is an invasion of property rights
and
SES so um we've heard this bill before
and um it its fate is probably going to
be no different this year than it was in
previous years that said I still feel
very compelled to speak in favor of the
bill I do so because uh of several
reasons reason number one um in Prior
years it's been a student Le Health
Initiative on why the bill was presented
to us in the first place and and you
know not for nothing we would always
like to encourage young people to be
feeling that they can make a difference
in their government and that that is
really important uh lesson for them to
see and learn um
second the statistics about secondhand
smoke and the the delorious effect it
has on a person's health
are
um well proven in my mind and um
the problem is
that because children and this covers
children because children often have to
ride in the
car with a person who smokes and they
have no control over that who looks out
for their interest who protects them um
we do require seat belts for for uh
persons under the age of 18 because
that's a really important thing to do
and and that is uh has strong bipartisan
support throughout throughout the state
for many for decades now um this is an
example where we have an obligation to
protect children who may have to ride in
a car where they don't have any control
and it is really bad for the health um
we did hear in Prior years excellent
testimony about how
opening the windows in your car actually
the front windows while a person is
smoking actually makes it worse for the
smoke to get into the back of the car
and
um I just for for a variety of reasons I
think that we as a
um we as a society have to yes we have
to weigh privacy results and uh uh
concerns yes we have to weigh uh uh uh
government governmental reach but
generally
speaking we are in support of protecting
those members of society who do not have
a voice and who are not protected by
anyone other than us passing legislation
that makes sense to protect them and I
as I and I would urge my colleagues to
think long and carefully and hard about
how
we do we do have that obligation to
protect children and that's what this
bill is about this bill is about
protecting children who are riding in
vehicles where uh folks who probably
shouldn't smoke in the car while they're
there but still do
set anybody else from the
committee representative St Clair
thank you Mr chair I uh I'm disappointed
that the uh the sponsor wasn't here for
this and I I'm glad that uh
representative Sykes brought up the uh
fact that there were students here uh
the last time this was discussed I think
they made a a really good a a good
presentation it's too bad that we can't
pass laws to uh have good parenting and
against bad parenting you know it just
it doesn't work and I get that the fact
that this is a secondary though a
secondary uh enforced law uh I think
uh makes me want to vote for it
because I guess if you're thick enough
to to not get rid of it before you get
stopped or something uh so be it I don't
think it's a bad a bad message to send I
don't think it's going to pass on the
floor but nonetheless uh I think it's
it's worthy of uh being pushed in that
direction
thank you representative Gorski thank
you Mr chairman
um this bill came up last term and I
actually was uh speaking against the
bill and here's what strikes me the
purpose of this
bill is not to
smoke with kids who are under 16 in the
car but according to how it's
written as long as I obey the rules of
the road
I could smoke to my heart's content and
the police won't pull me over because
they can't pull me over if I'm smoking
with someone who's less than 16 years 16
years old in the car it defeats the
purpose of the bill because if I follow
the rules of the road I can still do it
so this bill I thought was just not
ready for prime time and that's why you
know I I really can't support
it anybody else from the
committee representative St Clair wants
another stab yeah I'll make it quick I
uh I I see the reason for the secondary
uh enforcement because uh we can't
expect law enforcement to to see
somebody going by at whatever speed and
oh I think they had a cigarette going or
I think they had a vape going that makes
it hard however again if you stop
somebody and you walk up to the vehicle
and then there's smoke coming out
they're vaping in front of you or
smoking and they get kids under under
the age in the back then you know I
guess they've left left themselves open
to an education whatever that education
may be a warning uh a ticket or whatever
but I understand why it wouldn't work as
a primary thing because it would be near
impossible and I would hate to think
giving uh law enforcement a reason for
uh probable causeing I think I saw a
smoke coming out of here I think you
were doing something that's why I
stopped you and oh by the way now that I
got you but enough thank you
right so representative Johnson next
thank you um this is the kind of bill
that I wish had been on the books when I
was a kid uh I've been on the wrong end
of it too many times and that's why I'll
be supporting this
bill representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman um even worse than trying to
have a police officer determine whether
someone was smoking in there it's going
to be even harder to say I think they're
16 um or 14 or 15 so I don't don't know
how you could ever do it um and unless
it's a second second um infraction but
um I agree for that reason then with uh
Vice chair kski that um if if
someone if someone maintains their uh
control of their car in a reasonable
fashion they'll never get pulled over
and this will continue to exist so what
representative Miller thank you uh to to
sort of directly address uh
representative hilling Gorski there what
the hell is the point the point is we
make incremental improvements we help
protect the people we can when we can
and where we can it's not going to be a
Panacea none of these are but we help
the people we can especially those who
can't help themselves when and where we
can thank
you anybody else representative guys I
guess my big privacy concern comes back
to something representative Sinclair
said earlier also and that's that we
can't legislate good parenting you know
people should not be smoking around
their kids but we can't go into
somebody's private residence to
determine if that's happening that would
be a violation of multiple articles of
state and federal
Constitution now we're applying
different laws to your property and
what's within your reach on your vehicle
which is mobile um you know yes there's
a precedent for it that there's
different restraint laws for kids and
those are you know based on uh growth
and development and there's a growth and
development Dynamic over here do I think
that kids should be smoked around in
general no I don't do I think that
parents should not smoke in front of
their kids in a car I agree with that
but I don't think that it's within our
purview to reach into people's homes or
into people's cars to restrict adult
conduct drop the mic anybody else from
the
committee seeing nothing I'll ask the
clerk to call the rooll motion on the
floor is inexpedient to legislate on
368 Vice chairman Gorski yes I think the
clerk's going to vote Yes representative
Hill yeah representative voy yes
representative
Peto yes representative Koker yes
representative gas yes representative
Hamlin yes representative Sykes no
representative Sinclair no
representative Fox no representative Ao
No representative Johnson no
representative hon no representative
yes7 it is I knew good guess our
recommendation of inexpedient legislates
adopted
97 uh obviously regular calender it goes
I'll close the executive session on
health Bill
368 want to do a half a dozen more yes
no n I won't do that the ranking member
will never the ranking member will never
speak to me
again okay next up H build I'm
playing all right before we take off
thank you everybody we got a lot done
today we'll stop at s exact we're in
actually pretty good
shape uh we will meet again next Tuesday
I done the schedule yet but we do have
session this Thursday so a couple
things
um sure representative Sykes yes have
you spoken with representative G are you
still going to speak to anything on the
floor with House Bill apparently we have
determined that we're not going to just
let it go to a voice Voice vote yeah
okay unless somebody speaks against it
for some reason but I don't proceive
that so I will keep whose name's on
there to speak for the committee in case
somebody speaks to it the way it was
yeah or
you how did you in other words what I do
with the clerk usually just for
everybody's knowledge especially the
Freshman so before before every house
session I have to put together a debate
sheet on all the people who are going to
defend our committee
reports um that would be both either
doing the speech and then the
Parliamentary inquiry sometimes it's the
same person sometimes I split it up so
in this particular case we don't I don't
expect anybody to speak against it so
the clerk if doesn't see any opposition
to it won't call the person speaking for
it unless I ask him to um I just want to
make sure I'm putting the right person
down that wants to cover this if
something happens otherwise I will cover
cover fair enough that's what I want to
do that um thank you and and again too
this is it's a great bill it's a great
it's a great cause but when we get to
the house or it should be efficiency
purposes if we don't have a fight on
this we shouldn't be taking up time on
um representative pataro you're okay
defending that
bill um for Thursday my uh handicap
license we bill yeah yeah I'll I'll be
good I'll have some material ready to go
just in case and the only change I saw
the regular
calendar we I'll take credit for the
mistake too except they didn't get
caught in the uh at the speaker's office
either we were okay with the consent on
the conservation license plate for uh C
CYO bacteria but it did have a greater
fiscal note than I thought it did so
that is going to go to the regular
calendar it has to um my mistake uh
again we've done this in the past we
were fine with it but it can't go to to
the consent so that will be coming off
who would like to defend the committee
report on the conservation plate for
Sino
bacteria are you
sure yeah you're a Lakes Region
guy yep fair enough you got it
right no I got enough to do okay so I
thank you for that I I'll put you on the
so um anything else I think I've got
everything else covered again I'll put
week do you want to talk about the uh
next next session day uh not this
Thursday the following Thursday is the
governor's budget proposal
and we're going oh maybe you left early
so we're going to go into session break
for the Governor's um presentation and
then go on after that um and normally
the governor the next day presents the
budget but it's going to be done at on
Friday that week um at in the afternoon
if in case you wonder the
U no but if you want to hear the
governor's
um more elaborate
um explanation of her budget proposal
it'll be done at Finance Friday
afternoon Finance Finance Friday
afternoon so not not the normal way I
guess is my
point she's going to be doing that
Thursday the normal way but
normally there's another one the next
day yep the other part is there's going
to be two um there's still not going to
be a session day on the last weekend of
this the last week of this month but
there'll be session days the other that
leading up to that every
Thursday that's all I left the chair's
meeting early today so we could get
prepared for today's festivities thank
you for that representative Hill all
that stuff will be noticed in the
calendar as well too right just giving a
no no I know I just for for those just
to back up the info representative
blondon yeah just quickly uh Mr chair
you planning on SCH a meeting for next
Tuesday the 11th yeah okay yeah no we're
going to keep moving forward we'll stop
I see no need for us to be here for
school break which is that would the
last week 25th yeah so yeah we can
celebrate a the quick end to February
spring is almost here except for that
rodent who the other day who said six
more weeks um anything else for the good
of the cause being none are you go you
guys good what's that we're talking
that's what I I thought all right I
guess that concludes our business for
Thursday yes waiting to hear reports
please minority reports
waiting representative
SES minority reports before okay let me
know before you leave I got put it on
reports before you go please I get